Okay folks, I wanted to share a video on how much eabf, a computer, a laptop computer really gives off.
You can see that my meter can spike at different times, and I'm sure that's if it's receiving messages.
This laptop is connected to the Wi-Fi, so it is receiving Wi-Fi messages.
So you'll notice at different times it will spike.
So let's try just closing the computer and putting it to sleep and let's see what happens.
You see, this is what measures the, it's measuring at different areas of the computer.
If I move it farther away from the computer, literally on two inches from the computer, it literally drops to zero.
But when I put it way over where I'd be touching the computer with my hands,
you're getting eabf's with your playing with your computer when it's connected to the Wi-Fi.
But away from the computer, look at almost nothing.
There's just nothing away when it's a couple inches away from the computer.
Even let's close the computer so it goes to sleep, and let's see what happens.
Now even over the computer, there's very little, and it's still not even completely off or gone to sleep yet,
because I just closed the computer.
So you're not getting, I'm sending this on my body, you're not really getting any eabf's.
I'm actually probably picking up eabf's from my phone.
No, it's right up against my phone right now, see, and I'm getting more eabf's for my phone.
I ever did for my laptop.
Oh my goodness gracious, my hand is right there too.
I have this right, I can't get it over the camera.
There's the thing, now I'm putting it right over my phone behind my, next to my camera.
That's what's coming off my phone versus what's coming off the laptop.